bon poursuit avec le lancement du
contrat d'autonomie oui on reste dans
l'emploi avec notre invité tristan et
vert bonsoir vous êtes directeur général
adjoint à la mairie d'elancourt et donc
la mairie prend l'initiative de lancer
un contrat d'autonomie pour les 18 25
ans cette idée est venue de la réalité
du terrain c'était parce qu'il y avait
un vrai manque au niveau de l'insertion
professionnelle on pourra tout à fait
exact c'est le roi déploiement d'un
dispositif qui a été créée en 1300 du
précédent gouvernement c'était donc le
plan espoir banlieues qui et puis qui
pouvait bien sûr sur toutes les villes
qui disposent d'un contrat urbain de
cohésion sociale la mise en oeuvre de ce
contrat d'autonomie
il avait été mis en veille par la
préfecture sur certaines communes
cette année l'année précédente et il est
réactivé la tout récemment sur notamment
elancourt mais plusieurs autres villes
du département est donc bien sûr nous
sommes très volontariste pour que le
maximum de jeunes puissent en bénéficier
c'est un dispositif mis en place avec
différents partenaires
voilà en fait pour être tout à fait
simple et pragmatique s'il s'agit pour
les 18 25 ans qui sont en souffrance
dans leur recherche d'emploi dans leur
recherche de formation professionnelle
ou dans leur recherche de moyens pour
mettre en oeuvre leurs activités
professionnelles d'un coaching
personnalisé
qui leur est proposée sur une période
qui va de plusieurs semaines à plusieurs
mois puisque ça peut aller jusqu'à six
mois six mois d'un coaching personnalisé
pour l'heure de leur donner tous les
outils tous les moyens pour trouver un
emploi bien de trouver une formation
professionnelle ou bien créer leur
propre activité
c'est un dispositif qui est totalement
gratuit mieux que ça qui est rémunéré
pour les jeunes qui s'inscrivent dans ce
dispositif à hauteur de 300 euros par
mois et qui se veut donc vraiment
pragmatique et efficace
est-ce que vous avez un objectif de
jeunes que vous allez aider déjà alors
nous avons là dès maintenant que ja pour
la ville d'elancourt 25 places sur ce
dispositif
160 à l'échelle de saint quentin en
yvelines est beaucoup plus pour le
département et ce sont des jeunes que
vous allez suivre sur combien de temps
alors on imagine bien pour trouver un
emploi une fois qu'on a trouvé le suivi
est terminée alors tant mieux pour le
jeune si au bout de ce contrat
d'autonomie il est en emploi ou s'il est
en formation professionnelle
s'ils ne les peins il peut solliciter à
une prolongation
l'objectif c'est d'arriver à du concret
c'est vraiment un dispositif concret et
efficace qui a fait ses preuves
les deux années précédentes le contrat
d'autonomie vous disais c'est rémunéré
rémunéré à quelle hauteur alors ses 300
euros par mois pour les jeunes de 18 à
25 ans qui rentre dans ce dispositif sur
obligation de présence de présence
assidue
tous les jours c'est menée par le
cabinet c3 consultants qui situé ici à
guyancourt
pourquoi le choix de rémunérer aussi
c'est important c'est un vrai contrat de
travail c'est ça voilà c'est très
exactement avec des horaires à respecter
avec
des rencontres régulières avec les
employeurs des stages en entreprises et
tous les outils pour construire son cv
pour se préparer à l'entretien
d'embauché
et puis rentrer très active merci
beaucoup tristan hébert et puis on
suivra au fur et à mesure l'évolution de
ce contrat d'autonomie pour savoir un
petit peu plus et puis voir un petit peu
comment les jeunes ont pu être aidés